I I agreed with you to a certain extent  given I think ultimately it comes down  to your intention  so if you're if your intention is to  actually have a family I think there's a  biological clock that we can't  necessarily Overlook and you may say  that there's also yeah there are options  adoption and so forth but not every man  May necessarily want to take that route  so  my response was for an effect of my  version of a commitment where I am in my  life  I need to be with a woman that can I can  have a family with  and  with my age currently speaking  the higher up I go  I guess  if I want more than one child or so  forth that kind of has to be accelerated  and as a man  you know you've got a you've got to kind  of plan these things up but the planning  also takes time so  you know there's a point when I'm not  sure it's different for different  women's but from what I've learned in  school  there's a point where women can't  provide families